I mentioned earlier that I was in
Delaware last night pinch hitting for
Candace Owens at her speech he was
supposed to give because Candace flew to
Paris to open a fashion Show with Kanye
West which is the sort of thing that
Candace does and so I didn't hear any
more details than this other than I get
a call Candace is on the tarmac she says
okay this is what's happening and that's
it okay then I tune in I wait for the
international trending news and I see it
the shirt that Candace and Kanye wore
this is a shirt you can see the photo
from the back it says white lives matter
Candace there with a white shirt and
black Print White lives matter Kanye
there black shirt white print White
lives matter
I love it
I absolutely love it
they're getting some pushback obviously
they're getting pushed back from the
libs because the libs want to say black
lives matter
and they're getting some pushback from
the people in the middle because they
say oh you shouldn't say black lives
matter or White lives matter you should
just say all lives matter
but Kanye and Candace get it okay they
get it obviously they're being
intentionally provocative it's a fashion
show that's what you do at fashion shows
but they get the point here why would
you say White lives matter well from a
racial standpoint as long as we're
talking about black lives or all lives
or White lives
from a racial standpoint what they're
saying is
I think I don't want to speak for canvas
but this is just my interpretation of
the shirt
right now we have been told for years
that black people are marginalized and
discriminated against and insulted and
pushed to the margins of society and
that's why we need to say black lives
matter but that's not true actually
there is no legal discrimination or
systemic discrimination or really
discrimination at all certainly not at a
large scale against black people in fact
there's discrimination in favor of black
people through things like affirmative
action through certain applications of
the civil rights laws through the
culture certainly
through the popular media
the only group that you are actually
legally both legally allowed to
discriminate against and culturally
encouraged to discriminate against and
insult and Mock and push the fringes of
society the only racial group is white
people
that's what happens it's the only group
you're allowed to make fun of on TV
it's the only group white people and
Asians you're allowed to discriminate
against in college admissions and so I
don't know it's unfortunate for the
agents that they got lumped in with the
white people
but that's that's in jobs
in employment and all sorts of things
it's the white people and so they're
Kanye and Candace are coming out there
and provocatively saying
putting racial issues aside they're
saying as they frequently have
The Narrative that you are being fed by
the liberal establishment is not only
false it's the opposite of true
if they're actually presenting a vision
of reality the LeBron James black black
men can't walk out their doors without
being hunted down by racist cops it's
just completely made up the only people
who are being hunted down by the
government right now because of their
identity are white conservatives they're
like Midwestern grannies who who have
the audacity to raise some questions
about the 2020 election okay or pro-life
activists on the sidewalk
or parents of all Races who don't want
their kids
to be taught CRT and transgenderism in
schools
okay but then it's even more interesting
with the Kanye shirt because you
couldn't see it in the picture but on
the front of the Kanye shirt is a
picture of John Paul II
and it says we will follow your example
John Paul II
so
what White lives matter on the back John
Paul II on the front and then it hit me
again maybe I'm reading too deeply into
it
but it hit me at a higher level than
just this kind of silly talk about race
is the point that Kanye is making a
little deeper than that because the pope
wears white John Paul II wore white
Benedict wore white Francis wears white
the pope wears white a white soquetto a
white mozeta a white cassack a white
that's the symbol of the Pope
and is he suggesting something a little
deeper here that when we're talking
about
White lives matter we're not just
talking about
race we're talking about
something deeper we're talking about a a
symbol not of a particular racial group
but of Purity a symbol of the soul the
symbol of the Soul after baptism and uh
a symbol of a soul wearing a you know
sort of white garment these images that
we see in Paradise we know that Kanye
has had a conversion or reversion sort
of experience to Christianity we know he
talks about religious themes a lot we
know he has an album called Jesus as
king
is there maybe a suggestion here on this
provocative shirt that actually not only
is the BLM narrative bogus we're going
to debunk and own that with facts and
logic and provocation
but the whole racial narrative is kind
of a distraction from what we should
really be talking about
which is deeper not just cultural but
actually ultimately religious because
ultimately all human conflict is
theological that that's my read on it
again I don't know I don't know that
that's what was going through Kanye's
head I actually don't really care very
often the greatest artists are not
critics of their own work very often the
greatest artists don't even consciously
know what they are doing and this has
been written about going all the way
back to ancient Greece the idea that the
artists are just sort of receiving
inspiration from the muses and then
they're just doing stuff and the reason
there's a difference between artists and
critics is because very often the
artists couldn't even articulate exactly
what they're doing they're producing the
art and it's up to the critics to
interpret that sort of art right now
head on over to expressvpn.com Michael
YT let me ask you something what if
there were someone out there who kept a
log of every single thing you did every
minute of the day I think that would be
pretty creepy well what if I told you
that's exactly what happens every time
you go online your internet provider ATT
Comcast whoever is allowed to store logs
of every website you've ever visited and
can legally sell those data to anyone
that is why I trust expressvpn
expressvpn rewraps your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your internet provider can't see or
log what you do online now many of you
might be wondering well if I'm routing
all my data through a VPN then doesn't
that just mean the VPN can see what I'm
doing and log my data instead you're
right to worry about that except
while many vpns have a no logs policy
and they claim to have a no logs policy
many have been caught logging customer
activity expressvpn is the only VPN that
I trust because they use trusted server
technology they were the first major VPN
provider to engineer all of their VPN
servers to run in Ram this makes it
impossible for their VPN servers to
store any data including logs of any
expressvpn customers stop letting people
keep logs on what you do online head on
over right now to expressvpn.com Michael
YT find out how you can get three months
free
speaking of lives mattering speaking
speaking of a popular disregard for
human life
new details are emerging and I mentioned
this a few days ago maybe last week this
shooting of the 84 year old pro-life
lady in Michigan this retired nurse Joan
Jacobson
and shot by this uh crazy man a 74 year
old guy named Richard Harvey who says he
fired off a warning shot from his 22
caliber rifle when he heard his wife
arguing with his pro-life canvasser lady
and then he says he tried to push away
Jacobson's clipboard and said he
accidentally shot her in the front of
her shoulder accidentally fires a
warning shot he knows the gun is loaded
he's brandishing his gun and pushing
this 84 year old lady away and shoots
her in the shoulder
and she says I do think that he knew
what he was doing she says I think it
was intentional this woman is 120 pounds
and five feet tall
she says she didn't refuse to leave
their property when they asked she says
she never she didn't threaten anybody or
anything like that
certainly though there is no
reason to be brandishing a gun at an 84
year old woman who's five feet tall
ever even even if she's coming at you
with a hammer okay there's no reason to
be to have a gun certainly not a loaded
gun and to shoot her so why do I bring
this up because there was you want to
make sure you get getting the full story
here we do we still don't really know
the full story but
what we do know is as the full story is
coming out it is continuing to look
terrible for this guy
and and the way you know this by the way
is that the left-wing media are not
covering the story if the story really
were you know this awful woman was
threatening them and you'd be hearing
about it from the media but you're
seeing the media cover up this story and
so as the details come out yeah maybe
there's some complication here maybe the
maybe the pro-life lady was arguing with
the well no I'm not even sure that
that's the case
but as the details come out
we continue to look right
okay right and right and right and right
I do think people
are starting to notice that whether they
can take that noticing
and take that desire
and channel it into better government
that remains to be seen the rest of the
show is continuing now you do not want
to miss it
if you are not a member click the link
in the description and join us we have a
great interview coming up
it's with Michael schellenberger Michael
schellenberger is a really really
important voice
on environmental issues and Michael
schellenberger is is shedding some light
on what I think are not only the
ludicrous but downright offensive
Democrat claims about hurricane Ian and
and all the destruction down in Florida
which they they blame on global warming
and those mean old conservatives who
don't want to recycle or whatever Drive
Teslas and uh Schellenberg brings a
little bit of science to that so we will
get to him in just one second see you
over the member block
foreign
[Music]
[Music]